i knew that at some point he had to
admit
that he was going to use it but i said
why not now
and he said not it's not ready yet this
isn't the time yet
so i think what he is preparing for
is something really big on election
night
i know that this interview right now is
obviously your biggest interview of the
week but a few days ago
you did sit down with this other guy i'm
sure some of my audience has heard about
him before
uh this this donald trump fella
i'm sure some people have heard of him
um can you just tell me a little bit
sort of like what is the preparation as
an interviewer to do that i know you
have a relationship and he you know he
calls in and all that kind of stuff
um but like just what's it like sitting
down with the guy and and
trying to just make sense of the world
with him right now
you know as you as you said i've known
donald trump um for about 35 years
um my then husband al who answered the
phone
and fought with this sergeant he kept
saying
i'm not the assistant d.a janine is uh
represented donald for years so we spent
time most weekends going to florida
with donald um when my kids were little
and his kids were little
and um so i know the man i know donald
trump the man i
i have a sense of you know who he is
and um i i know a side of him
not the caricature that they make him
out to be i know that he's brilliant
but to answer your question directly how
do you sit down and prepare for it
um i try to first thing you do is you
figure out topics
what do you want to talk to them about
biggest issues right now
are the pandemic uh the rioting
and the looting of the election the
debate
joe biden is he capable and the things
that no one was talking about that i
thought was so important
were the nobel peace prize i mean the
abrahamic
wars just signed i mean talk about
israel the united arab emirates
israel and bahrain i mean this is big
stuff
and you know apparently the saudis are
about to follow
uh so i talked to him about that and um
i write my questions out and you know
i've never talked to anyone else at fox
on how they do it it's almost like
you're trying a case
you know but it's your direct case it's
not really a cross-examination
uh but you know that you're gonna have
to push a little bit
so what there are two questions where i
pushed
the one question was um look
said something like mr president i know
that you have to be invited
into certain areas in order to bring in
the national guard as you did in
milwaukee and as you did in kenosha
but there are some places they will not
just not have you in
and they'd rather see rioting and
looting uh
the word is that on election night
assuming that there's a winner
uh and if you win if you are the winner
uh and there are the promised riots
looting and anarchy what will you do he
said we'll put it down very quickly
what will you do we're going to put it
down very quickly what will you do
he said insurrection it's going to use
the insurrection act
and i you know i knew that at some point
he had to admit that he was going to use
it but
i said why not now and he said not it's
not ready yet this isn't the time yet
so i think what he is preparing for
is something really big on election
night where were you
on election night do you remember 2016
where are we
yeah i was on air uh on the daily wire
with ben shapiro and
and the crew over there and the the one
my one takeaway of the night i don't
know if you know
andrew clavin who's one of the hosts on
the daily wire he said something that i
thought was really brilliant that night
he said only in america could the thing
that everyone said couldn't happen
could happen and i thought well all
right whether you
whether you love trump or hate trump the
fact that something like that can happen
that
all the pundits could get it wrong all
the pollsters could get it wrong
all the elites could get it wrong that's
actually pretty beautiful
that that goes to the strength of our
democracy actually
you know and it really does go to the
strength of our democracy that it's not
so predictable it's not so
set in stone it's not as though people
are orchestrating it
um i remember coming out of the hilton
uh on election morning it was like 3 30
or 4 in the morning
and i was just so excited i mean i think
buzzfeed one of them had a picture of me
standing on a chair with a trump hat on
and i had the loudest dress i could wear
i was like orange flowers or something
and so i'm like dancing out of the hotel
and all of a sudden
somebody starts cursing at me and you
know and i look down and i look up the
guy's like
6'4 and he's cursing me out and
you know not not a shy new yorker i went
right back at him
uh although he was taller than me uh
although he was in a tutu
but he was really tall so uh the cops
said to me
judge come over here i said no make him
go
over there you know i'm really stupid
sometimes
you're a new yorker whatever the reason
is i was stupid
and so then they start another guy
started coming out cursing me she's a
trump person so
the reason i bring it up is i guarantee
you that 2020
if the president is announced as the
winner that night
it's going to be wild and um
i truly believe he will win i think that
even
people dave in those towns where there's
anarchy like portland and seattle and i
know those are liberal states
and uh like oregon and all that but
there are people now who are
afraid they're afraid they survived
kind of the pandemic and they have one
shot to get back their business
which is the security for their family
which is their
their their ego their sense of self
their sense of self worth our jobs are
who we
are and bang the protesters come in and
destroy it
i don't think they want the left
controlling that
and getting away with impunity this is
impunity
but it's not one thing dave it's not
like all of a sudden it was a perfect
storm
that george george um uh george floyd
died
and you know everybody said all right
let's revolt no you don't find bricks in
the middle of
a pandemic right nobody's building
anything in manhattan
and all of a sudden all over the country
there's no bail
statutes so everyone is being arrested
is being let out
and even the ones who are being arrested
they've now got prosecutors
who have been elected with the support
of the democrat socialists of america
who are saying
we're not prosecuting them we're not
putting people in jail
we're letting people out of jail and so
now this whole layer that we haven't
even noticed
is on fire and it is set
for a huge turnaround and this is the
last chance we have in this country to
secure
law and order so that all right so that
brings us to the book because
i i read a bunch of it this morning and
and the first the opening of the book in
essence
you say this is a battle of good and
evil
and you know i've sort of come around to
that like i don't like thinking that my
ideological enemies are evil and i think
a lot of them have good intentions
but i think in effect at this point this
thing that we're fighting that you're
talking about this this marxist
revolution
and antifa and blm and this whole thing
it has become evil
even if some of them do have good
intentions do you really believe that
this is this is sort of the last stand
that the you know we always say this is
the most important election ever but do
you really feel like
this is it like this is the the final
stand
you know you're right we always say it
people always say this is the most
important election in your lifetime
i really mean it this time i mean i
would take an oath
on this you know i would go to church on
this if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell